[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning this
week's inauguration will feature
long-standing traditions
marking the occasion despite
unprecedented challenges
president-elect biden plans to take the
oath of office on the west front steps
of the capitol
as other presidents have done for the
last 40 years
chief white house correspondent that's
nancy cordes got a behind the scenes
look
nancy good morning to you so what should
we expect it looks so different than
we've ever seen it before
it really does gail for starters this is
about as close as most people are going
to be able to get to the capitol
on inauguration day but even before this
unprecedented security stemming from the
uprising we saw a week and a half ago
the organizers were already contending
with a global pandemic as they tried to
maintain
many of the inaugural traditions that
americans are so familiar with so
what is it going to look like we asked
the man tasked with
bringing it all together so are they
done doing the plotting or do they say
major vargazi is the executive director
of the presidential inaugural committee
it's his job to plan the most
complicated inaugural ceremony
ever are you getting any sleep at this
point i'm getting
a couple hours a night a good friend of
mine checked in on me the other day and
he said
the signs were showing varghazi is no
stranger to big events
he was the ceo of the biden campaign
which had to re-imagine the democratic
national convention
and the election night celebration to
keep them covered safe
what were the elements of an
inauguration that were most
important to you to preserve so what we
wanted to do was preserve the images
that
people are used to when it comes to
seeing a peaceful transfer of power
we wanted president-elect biden to take
the oath on the west front
and we wanted to give people a sense
that you know we are still even in even
in tough times we're a resilient country
hi barack hussein obama after all
presidents have been getting sworn in
on the west front of the capitol for the
past 40 years
with one key difference generally that
platform would be packed
like people shoulder shoulder maybe up
to a thousand people up there
on wednesday to maintain social
distancing it'll be closer to 200
and the national mall will be completely
blocked off to the public
though that doesn't mean it'll be empty
well what you'll see on the mall
you know uh is going to be a sea of
flags
2009 i was here for president obama's
first inauguration
looking this way down toward the
monument on a bright day
and seeing people wave their flags in
the light
we wanted to capture some of that spirit
and so this weekend workers began
installing nearly 200
thousand american flags and state and
territory flags
all of it to show the american people
that were thinking about them in this
time
we spoke amid what felt like an armed
encampment
it was just 12 days ago that thousands
of rioters swarmed to the very spot
where president-elect biden will be
sworn in
we just had to add more security
minnesota senator amy klobuchar sits on
the congressional committee
that oversees inaugural events did you
ever consider
bringing the entire inauguration inside
and abandoning the west front
we thought should we do it on another
side should we do it inside
and time and time again we came back to
the point that
no this is where the inauguration
traditionally has been held not
when you go way back but traditionally
and we want to continue that tradition
there are some additional changes that
they are making to meet the moment
on wednesday as you know two capitol
police officers lost their lives as a
result of the riots and dozens more
were injured well cbs news has learned
that during the ceremony there will be
a recognition of the capital police
force
even as those officers are on duty
protecting the lawmakers and
all the other dignitaries who will be
there for the big event
yeah january 6 would be messy yeah and
yet they were successful and that no one
was hurt nancy thank you very much we
appreciate that and there are many
officers
that do deserve to be celebrated we've
heard the other stories of the selfies
and letting the barricades go but there
are many officers most officers we
should say
did the right thing but when i look at
those pictures guys it makes me sad but
it also makes me very angry that it's
come to them yeah and
and the threat will not pass after
inauguration date right
it will be out there and i should say
when i say no one was hurt i mean no
member of congress
and that is the mission of the capital
police some of this would have been like
this in
in part because of covey but but it this
is it's obviously been taken to a
different level i am glad
they are continuing the imagery of
having it out
uh on the west side of the capitol
because that will at least
uh be familiar all right that was our
chief white house correspondent nancy
cordes yeah
title there for her yes yes